madame la ministre lors de l'examen du
plfss pour 2010 9
votre collègue ministre du budget a
annoncé fièrement que le bon vieux trou
de la sécurité sociale qui aggrave les
déficits publics depuis 2002 allait être
rebouché
et cela dès 2019 disait-il avant le
retour à les clims promis par le premier
ministre dans son discours de politique
générale je vous ai bien écouter à
l'époque je vous cite pour la première
fois depuis 18 ans la sécurité sociale
retrouvera l'équilibré
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour les jeunes
générations la bonne nouvelle n'était
semble-t-il qu'une fake news puisque
finalement la sécurité sociale pourrait
être affiché à la fin d'année un déficit
de 3 milliards 6 ce qu'annonce le haut
conseil de financement de sécurité
sociale dans son rapport du mois de mars
ce rapport précise l'un aucun équilibre
n'est envisageable avant la fin du
quinquennat
les promesses d'un petit excédent de 600
millions d'euros se sont envolés le
discours de fin d'année a été happée à
la réalité
comment madame la ministre pouvez vous
expliquer et justifier un tel décalage
entre les prévisions présentées comme la
preuve incontestable de la bonne gestion
du gouvernement et la réalité des
chiffres qui seront ceux de la fin de
l'année 2019 quels objectifs se fixe
désormais le gouvernement en termes de
réduction du déficit de la sécurité
sociale enfin comment allez-vous en
l'absence d'excès d'en financer les
nouveaux moyens confié à la cades est ce
ces nouveaux moyens n'avait été déclaré
conforme à la constitution qu en raison
d excédent prévisionnel du budget de la
sécurité sociale on répandre la parole
de la ministre des solidarités de la
santé mme n'abusant avait la parole de
la ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur
président alain millions vous avez
raison
évidemment pas une fake news c'est
simplement l'évolution des comptes vous
le savez nous avons présenté un budget
qui devait être à l'équilibré en 2010 9
lors du père fss 2019 que nous avons
sur lequel nous avons travaillé à
l'automne le haut conseil de financement
de la protection sociale prévoit
effectivement maintenant un déficit de 3
6 milliards d'euros pour 2019
je veux quand même rappeler les efforts
considérables qui ont été faits dans la
gestion pour redresser les comptes
sociaux
lou gouvernement en effet présenté avec
gérald darmanin le plus faible déficit
annuel de la sécurité sociale depuis
2001 lors de la clôture des comptes en
2018 nous l'avons présenté au mois de
mars 2019 le déficit fin 2018 atteignait
mois 1,2 milliard d'euros soit une
réduction de 3,9 milliards d'euros par
rapport à 2010 tête
donc nous avons eu une gestion tout à
fait remarquable des comptes sociaux
cela montre concrètement le sérieux
budgétaire et financier du gouvernement
pour 2019 maintenant il y a eu la loi
vous le savez la loi votée le 21
décembre 2018
portant des mesures d'urgence économique
et social qui a réduit defacto les
recettes des administrations de sécurité
sociale
et cela à deux titres d'abord
l'anticipation en janvier 2019 de
l'exonération des cotisations sociales
sur les heures supplémentaires
cela revient à un manque de recettes de
moins 1,3 milliard d'euros
et puis nous avons également
l'annulation de la hausse de la csg pour
les retraités modestes de moins de 2000
euros de pension et cela revient à mon
que recettes de la sécurité sociale 2
mois 1,3 milliard d'euros
ceci explique les projections du haut
conseil de financement de la protection
sociale
maintenant nous allons travailler tous
ensemble pour améliorer ce déficit de
façon à reprendre la trajectoire
initialement prévu évidemment cela sera
présenté lors du plfss leur 2020 je vous
remercie monsieur le président bilan oui
merci madame un problème
ministre mais les prévisions du
haut-conseil remettent en cause
malheureusement est sérieusement la
viabilité financière du projet de
réforme des retraites en particulier
vous faites le choix le gouvernement ont
fait le choix d'une communication sur le
maintien de l'âge de la retraite à 62
ans
dire la vérité aux français sur la
nécessité de prolonger l'effort
entrepris par les précédentes réformes
me semble être de nature à créer la
confiance
[Applaudissements]